primeur c'est la première fois qu'un
musée des beaux-arts ouvre ses portes à
omar ba l'artiste sénégalais qui partage
sa vie entre genève et dakar veut
maintenant séduire le public d'ici avec
cette exposition elle présente vingt
tableaux rétrospective d'une décennie de
travail de ce peintre engagé coup de
coeur de nathalie bondil une troublante
beauté
il ya à la fois donc
beaucoup de délicatesse et en même temps
beaucoup de violence dans chacune des
oeuvres c'est qu'une peinture totalement
inédite un talent fou une
profonde pertinence sur les enjeux
globo la corruption du pouvoir les
guerres meurtrières le terrorisme et
régimes tyranniques les inégalités le
pouvoir de l'argent avec ses personnages
étranges et inquiétants mi-humain
mi-animal omar dénonce vilipende
pourfend critique en prenant soin
d'enrober ces messages durs dans une
douceur une beauté esthétique
ça me permet de traiter un sujet qui est
qui qui violent est de le mettre sur un
fond de plumage qui est très très doux
dingues ou du haut quand on regarde bien
car on a on est devant on a la sensation
que c'est beau que c'est agréable à voir
mais en mer un message qui peut être dur
et violent
la majorité des tableaux d'omar ba sont
peints sur du carton ondulé
ils les enduits d'abord de noir avant de
dessiner ses personnages
c'est ainsi qu'il a peint cette oeuvre
sur place
l'artiste a travaillé pendant six jours
sur ce tableau baptisé la monnaie comme
outil de développement
omar ba a voulu ici dénoncer la
domination de l'occident sur l'afrique
via les banques et l'argent une oeuvre
éphémère elle doit être détruite
à la fin de l'exposition en novembre
mais le musée négocié avec l'artiste
pour l'acquérir faut vraiment qu'on
trouve une solution parce que c'est une
oeuvre exceptionnelle
omar ba l'artiste engagé à cheval entre
l'afrique et l'occident porteur de
message universel et d'un art africain
contemporain remarquable ici catherine
françois radio canada montréal